[Music]
sorry yelling at me like what you have
serious anger issues
things turned nasty on Wednesday after
Rob Kardashian and blac Chyna went to
war on social media hurling accusations
at one another that include cheating
drugs and domestic abuse here's a look
back at their relationship in January
2016 the pair first got together which
caused tension amongst the Kardashians
remember China is the ex-fiance of Kylie
Jenner's then boyfriend Tyga and mother
of their son King Robb proved he was in
it for the long haul literally he drove
from LA to Texas to pick China up after
she was arrested for public intoxication
and drug possession then the engagement
in April Rob popped the question with a
seven carat ring a month later they
announced they were expecting their
first child together BAM Robert
Kardashian you are the father things
seem to be going well but in September
we saw their volatile relationship play
out on their reality show Rob and Chyna
the fact that you kept accusing me of
doing oh you're the one accident xfe
knows Rob then on November 10th their
daughter dream was born and the former
couple seemed to put aside their
differences but just a month later in
December things took a turn for the
worse Rob announced on snapchat that
China had moved out of their family home
with their daughter and nearly all their
furniture a few weeks later Rob had a
diabetes health-related scare a source
told ET at the time that the couple was
quote focusing on their relationship
just being happy with you
but it didn't take long for that to
combust by March 2017 the couple called
it quits and canceled season two of
their reality show
fast forward to July and it's a
full-blown social media war a new psycho
what's wrong my business and relax Rob
accused China of cheating and doing
drugs while she clapped back with
allegations of domestic abuse